سنتحدث الان عن خارطه الوظائف في 20 23
على الرغم العمليات تصريح الموظفين في
شركات تكنولوجيا الكبرى وهنا المفارقه حصل
مطور البرمجيات على المركز الاول كذلك في
قائمه افضل الوظائف لمؤسسه يو اس نيوز
ادورد ريبورت الاعلاميه مطور البرامج حقق
ارتفاعا من المركز الخامس في قائمه العام
الماضي الترتيب جاء بناءا على تحليلا
اجرته المؤسسه لبيانات شمل الطلبات
التوظيف ومتوسط الراتب اضافه لمستوى
الاجهاد وتوازن بين العمل والحياه
وبالنسبه لاولائك الذين يبحثون عن اقصى
درجات الامان الوظيفي اوضحته واسمي يوزن
العاملين في مجال الرعايه الصحيه منذ
قاردات ومديريه خدمات طبيه والصحيه كانوا
في اعلى مستويات بالنسبه للمهن التي تتمتع
باعلى مستوى من الامان نتابع مزيدا من
الوظائف
اذا نتعرف على اكثر الوظائف في طلبا في
عام 2023 بحسب يو اس نيوز
مطور البرامج يتصدرون هذه القائمه ولرعايه
الصحيه نصيب كبير من هذه القائمه فالمرتبه
الثانيه هي من نصيب الممرض المتدرب
اما ثالثا في القائمه فجاءت وظيفه مدير
الخدمات الطبيه والصحيه وفي المركز الرابع
نبقى في مجال الرعايه الصحيه مع مساعد
طبيب معالج وفي المركز الخامس محلل او
معلومات وفي المركز السادس معالج فيزيائي
المدير المالي جاء في المركز السابع من
هذه القائمه وفي المركز الثامن مدير
التكنولوجيا المعلومات المركز التاسع من
القائمه من نصيب مطور المواقع الالكترونيه
وفي المركز العاشر والاخير من هذه القائمه
جاء طبيب الاسنان
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا من جده طيران
مستشار تطوير القيادي والاعمال الافتراضي
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك
منوركم وما شاء الله راجعون
تشعر فيها وراحه فانا سالت قالوا لي انه
علميا الجبال يعني تطلق ذبذبات وفيه يعني
علميا في طاقه جميله تخرج من الجبال
والصخور
اكثر مكان بعيد عن الاجهزه الالكترونيه
في قمه اتصالك مع الطبيعه وتشوف النجوم
ترجعي انت كده متصله مع كل ما حولك اللبس
ههه طيب يعني بحسب الدراسه يعني في مهن في
يعني في التصدر القائمه رغم التصريح
الجماعي فيها وتراجع السوق العمل كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك خصوصا مطوير والبرامج
دوله ورجال لكن التكنولوجيا المنحنى الذي
لا ينحد
فضاء والتضخم يعني صحه ومال
احد للموظف كلها تندرج حولت ثلاثاء
الثالوث الاعظم
عشان يصحح معلومه انه الشركات التكنولوجيا
خسرت موظفين او خرجت موظفين كثير لكن
بالعكس هم القوا وبوظتوا مبرمجين وما الان
البرمجه وتكنولوجيا صارت تغنيني عن بعض
كثير من الوظائف انا اول احتاج مسوق
واحتاج مدرمين واحتاج خلاص الان في برامج
تسويقيه برامج ولاء للعملاء برامج حتى
التغريدات والبوستات والتسويق اللي بيصير
انا الان في برامج تقدر تحطه فيها
تغريداتك لمده شهرين ثلاثه اربعه وتطلع كل
يوم في الوقت اللي انت تختاريه خيري قد
ايش في وظائف هنستغنى عنها نرجع مره ثانيه
نشوف اكثر الوظائف امانه هي المتعلقه
بالوباء الاخصائيين همم الاجهزه التنفس او
الجهاز التنفسي والناس اللي مختصين في
الفاينايش همم
من اين ناتي بالمال وكيف نصرفه يعني كل
الموضوع يتم هذه الاركان الاساسيه لكن
الان خلينا نرجع لشرجي بيتي المجالس يغير
خارطه التكنولوجيا الان زي ما تفضلتوا في
لقائكم مع الخبيره التقني بيقول لك انا
مبرمج كنت اجلس بالساعات وبرمج كودات حق
سكيوتي الان يبرمج لي في ثلاث ثواني
دكتور كان اخصائي نفسي بيتكلم عن تحت
اعظم من هون لعشر سنين في العقد القادم طب
ما هي الوظائف التي يمكن الحديث عنها انه
تشعرك في امان وظيفه والسلام لمن لا
يبحثون عن التطور والشغب
مره ثانيه الان البرمجه هي اللغه العصر
اللي لا يعرف برمجه يعتبر لغه انجليزيه
يعتبر امي الان اللي ما يعرف او اللي ما
يعرف كمبيوتر او يتعامل مع التكنولوجيا
يعتبر
امي انت سهله الان فيكم
كل هذه المواقع التعليميه بامكانك تاخذي
فكره عن موضوع برمجه الموقع الالكتروني عن
موضوع كيف تدير حساباتك وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي كيف انت تكوني في امان لما ما
تهتم به فقط على مصدر واحد من الداخل كيف
ممكن يكون لك مصدر اخر وصار مثلا الان
موضوع الخبراتك ممكن تتحول الى تكنولوجيا
حطيها تسجليها وتعتبر لك داخل جديد كثير
من الناس الان كيف صاروا يعتمده على
التكنولوجيا ان هو نفسه اللهم صادر داخلي
او بداخلي العمل اخرى عشان لا يكون في خطر
انه في يوم من الايام ايش ما صار في
العالم هيجوا يقولوا لي شكرا مع السلامه
ايش ممكن يكون خبره اللي انا اشتغلتها في
اي مكان ممكن تكون بديل يدخل لي دخله انا
اعرف شخصيات اعلاميه وشخصيات مؤثرين في
المجتمع وشخصيات على وظائفهم الان جالسين
يعملوا كونتنت ومحتوى
لانه في المرتبه الاولى مطوروا البرامج في
المرتبه الثانيه الرعايه الصحيه والخدمات
الصحيه الا اما ده بالفعل هناك مهن مهما
يعني طال الزمن لا يستغنى عنها
الاساسيات اللي الناس بيعيشوا عليها يعني
في النهايه قد ما يكون في فلوس قد ما يكون
في تطور انا لازم اعتمد على الصحه يعني
احتاج فيها احياش كبير جدا واعجبني جدا في
نفسك تقريبا لميس في الموضوع البروتيكشن
الحمايه ترى الناس مختصين وعلماء وضاحين
في الحمايه ضد الامراض والاوبئه والحجابات
الاخرى كيف ممكن عشان ما احتاج اني امرض
وهذا توجه صافي وزاره الصحه سعوديه
التمرين والممرضات المرخصات كيف هم من
اوائل القائمه في الاحتياج هذا لانه زي ما
احنا شايفين لازال تاثير الجائحه بس نسمعه
ويوم القيامه مدري مين ومتحولات بتحصل في
الجهاز الصحيحي او القطاع الصحي هو من
اعظم القطاعات على مدى التاريخ وسيضل طبعا
لكن اللي اجمل اللي شفته في القائمه جدا
هو موضوع عن الوقايه وكيف ممكن نتحرص منها
او نت بدا الوقوع في الامراض مره ثانيه يا
مدير وسهام الفكره كلها كيف ممكن اركز
اني اتعلم
التاء المرتب
طه كيف ممكن اوفر في موضوع الانتاج كيف
ممكن اتابع موضوع الكاميرات الجديده كيف
كل واحد في تخصصهم ماليا بتيجي انظمه ثاب
وارجل وغيرها كيف ممكن اتعلم عليها في كل
خط كيف ممكن اشوف الجانب الالكتروني اخر
حاجه بس في معلومه جميله في فيديو جدا
الرائعه بيوريكي كوبرا الشركات في العالم
كيف كان الترتيبها وكيف بدا مفتاح متحبط
ويطلع مكانه هات تدريجيه شركات
التكنولوجيا في اي شخص لكي يستمر في القمه
تعال تكنولوجيا بما انك قلت على تشاد جي
بي تي بس سريعا يعني مثلا اذا واحد بيحب
القراءه كثير والكتابه كثير كبيره ومحتاج
انه يلخصه
بلخص لك ابرز المعلومات سواء بارتيكل او
حتى يعني في كتاب فهي كمان بنوظف بنوظف في
زكاه ملخص اذا انت تجيب الملخص
شكرا لك